salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui on
va parler de l'analyse transactionnelle
à la fin de cette vidéo vous serez en
mesure de mieux gérer votre temps parce
que vous allez mieux comprendre comment
il découle cette théorie parce que c'est
une théorie a été fondée par un
psychiatre dans les années 50 qui
s'appelle eric berne c'était un
psychiatre qu'est né au canada et qui
ensuite a vécu aux états unis à cette
époque tout le monde se disait fraude
c'est le nouveau génie il a raison il
avait raison sur plein de choses
peut-être pas sur tout mais ça c'est un
autre débat
eric byrne décide alors de construire sa
propre théorie en regardant les liens
qui a entre la structure psychologique
et la communication et là ça devient
très intéressant parce que tout l'enjeu
de sa théorie c'est de prendre
conscience en permanence de caisse
qu'ils jouent maintenant au moment
présent entre nous et les autres c'est
une évidence mais aussi vis-à-vis de
nous-mêmes vis-à-vis du fameux jeu en
découle donc six structures du temps qui
passe d'un point de vue relationnel
vis-à-vis des autres donc le fait de les
connaître ses six structures ça nous
permet d'en prendre conscience de les
étirer de les resserrer de peut-être en
enlever au bénéfice de choses plus
productives ou justement pour plus se
détendre avoir conscience c'est avoir le
pouvoir
première structure c'est le retrait
qu'on soit tout seul ou dans un groupe
c'est le fait de se mettre un discours
intérieur d'être dans ses pensées soient
dans l'imaginaire sont en train de
réfléchir un exemple très concret c'est
quand vous arrivez au sein d'un groupe
d'amis que ce soit au travail ou en
cours quand vous êtes en cours vous vous
posez avec tout le monde sans forcément
dire bonjour vous êtes avec eux mais
vous leur parlez pas encore soit vous
écoutez ce vous êtes dans vos pensées
la deuxième structure c'est le rituel on
passe énormément de temps à faire
beaucoup de rituels ça n'apportera rien
à l'échangé ça n'apporte rien
relationnel ça n'apporte rien à la
conversation et ça n'apporte rien dans
notre rapport avec l'autre c'est comme
ça c'est les bonjour bon week-end la
semaine prochaine passe de bonnes
vacances banane et bien sûr mais toi ça
va oui moi ça va et toi ça va oui ça va
mais moi aussi ça va troisième structure
qui apporte énormément de choses elle
par contre dépassé celle qu'on appelle
le passe temps comme son nom l'indiqué
nous rapporte pas grand chose c'est le
fait de passer le temps avec une
personne qu'on connaît pas ou peu ou des
fois qu'on connaît mais dont le lien le
feeling ne permet pas de faire autre
chose que le passe temps alors on va
dire que les anciens parlent de la pluie
et du beau temps en vrai tout le monde
le fait même les jeunes on va parler de
ce qu'on a mangé hier
on va parler de ce qu'on a fait hier
alors qu'il s'est rien passé de vraiment
terrible on va parler d'un fait
d'actualité un petit peu basiques dont
tout le monde parle en ce moment ça
c'est la structure du passe-temps
quatrième structure c'est l'activité
c'est celle qu'il a nous permet
d'atteindre un but un objectif que ce
soit amical que ce soit sociale que ce
soit dans le travail que ce soit sportif
que ce soit peu importe si par exemple
je change avec quelqu'un pour qu'on
puisse voir à faire des choses plus tard
sur la chaîne et que du coup on essaie
de se trouver un rendez-vous un lieu et
une date
là on est en plein dans l'activité de
l'activité s'est pas forcément celle
qu'on est en train de pratiquer
réellement c'est déjà le fait de parler
de discuter de se donner des choses à
faire de se répondre ça c'est l'activité
c'est très important
la 5ème structure c'est le jeu et dans
le jeu j ai eue il ya le jeu j e
c'est pas le jeu en terme de loisirs ça
on mettrait plus d'ailleurs dans
l'activité sont les jeux qui obéissent à
des règles précises relationnel
transactionnel qui sont souvent néfaste
puisque chacun un rôle déterminé il ya
quelqu'un qui peut souffrir de ce jeu et
surtout le jeu va se répéter entre les
personnes tout au long de leur vie
jusqu'à temps que le schéma soit cassée
par l'un ou l'autre ces faits de non
dits mais pourtant il ya des règles très
précises en dessous c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit beaucoup en politique il y
avait quand jacques chirac
ohlala qu'est ce qui les gêne fabien
quand je dirais que s'était présenté aux
élections présidentielles il était face
à un millier de cas rang duquel il avait
été ministre à l'époque
donc il était en débat d'égal à égal et
chirac avait précisé un moment donné je
me suis un peu exactement des mots mais
comme il était candidat au même titre
que françois mitterrand il n'avait pas à
l'appeler monsieur le président il
pouvait l'appeler françois mitterrand et
ce à quoi françois mitterrand avait
répondu mais tout à fait monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes deux
candidats vous me permettrez donc de
vous appeler monsieur me dire mais vous
avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
premier ministre
et là on voit exactement de quelles
manières mitterrand avait humilié chirac
dans cette phrase c'est un jeu de non
dit il ya un jeu quand même qui
s'installe c'est comme si je faisais
tomber mon stylo à répétition pour que
toujours la même personne le ramasse
tout en sachant en ramassant que je
l'avais fait tomber exprès mais qu'elle
n'est pas d'autre choix de le ramasser
c'est ça qu'on appelle le jeu donc si
vous passez plus de temps et dans le jeu
avec une personne que dans l'activité
c'est pas une bonne relation peu importe
de quel côté vous êtes du jeu et enfin
l'intimité qui est la meilleure relation
qu'on peut avoir avec quelqu'un
l'intimité encore une fois c'est au sens
large du terme c'est tout les relations
que vous allez avoir avec des personnes
privilégiées ou
vous vous sentez acceptées elles se
sentent accepter aussi c'est tout à fait
pas nous hissant pour les deux c'est la
base des relations qui sont franches qui
sont loyales souvent qu'ils sont directs
qui sont précises il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté il n'y a pas besoin de grands
échanges verbaux pour sa part exemple il
ya quelque chose qui vient de se passer
devant moi qui m'a beaucoup fait rire et
je vais tourner la tête vers quelqu'un
qui est près de moi avec un sourire et
je sais qu'il aura compris pourquoi j'ai
sourire et je sais qui c'est ça c'est
l'intimité vous invite vraiment à
retenir ses six structures je vous le
met dans le descriptif je vais vous
mettre aussi de lien pour ceux qui
veulent aller un peu plus loin dans
l'analyse transactionnelle et déjà dès
maintenant vous pouvez vous poser la
question de quelle est la structure la
plus présente dans ma vie kate ce qui se
passe le plus et le plus souvent si vous
avez des doutes sur une structure lié à
un échange vous pouvez mettre dans les
commentaires n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à
admettre et puis moi je vous répondrais
je suis sûr que d'autres aussi passeront
pour répondre mais on peut en parler
ensemble juste là une fois vous serez
aguerris à savoir qu'est ce qui se joue
quels sont les enjeux qui se passe à
chaque moment et à chaque échange avec
quelqu'un alors vous serez capable de
régler ces échanges la plus facilement
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que ces échanges la entre
nous vous aurons plus si c'est le cas
vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air et
ça c'est gratifiant
pensez à vous abonner avant de partir
pour pas rater deux vidéos pour pas
avoir de retard puisqu'elle sorte vite
puisque en a une par jour et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao